mehr tun fürs klima die grünen drängen
auf schnellere und ehrgeizigere
maßnahmen beim umweltschutz
gewaltwelle in hongkong polizei und
demonstranten liefern sich erbitterte
gefechte em-ticket für 2020 die deutsche
fußball-nationalelf hat sich die
teilnahme vorzeitig gesichert
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster die nachrichten um 7
willkommen am sonntagabend bei mir für
den sport heute norbert könig ja sehr
gerne genommen geschlossen harmonisch
und doch kampfeslustig so präsentierten
sich die grünen auf diesem bielefelder
parteitag und erklärten sich bereit auch
im bund regierungsverantwortung zu
übernehmen was sie von den
regierungsparteien unterscheidet zeigte
sich heute vor allem in viel
weitergehenden beschlüssen zum
klimaschutz aber in einklang mit der
wirtschaft hieß es andreas huppert
demonstrativ geschlossen und froh
gelaunt so präsentieren sich die grünen
zum abschluss ihres parteitags er
mittelpunkt heute der markenkern der
klimaschutz und heute anfang so schwer
dass es aus der opposition heraus
verwandelt wird dieses system gehen wir
dieses system
[Applaus]
damit das gelingt soll deutschland
spätestens 2035 klimaneutral werden
beschlossen wurde auch ein co2 preis von
60 euro pro tonne schon ab dem nächsten
jahr über weitere steigerungen
entscheidet danach eine kommission
wir wollen nicht eine debatte führen
dass wir dadurch die soziale schieflage
in deutschland verschärfen wir müssen
die ländlichen räume mit denken und
dürfen ist nicht nur akademisch
betrachten
zur entlastung der bürger solle es
deshalb ein energie geld in höhe von
mindestens 100 euro geben
ein weiterer beschluss die anhebung des
mindestlohns auf 12 euro ergebnisse mit
denen auch die kritische grüne jugend
gut leben kann dafür sorgen dass wir
hier und jetzt uns aufmachen und dafür
sagen dass meine generation auf diesem
planeten noch leben kann
vereinbarkeit von wirtschaft und
ökologie dafür haben die grünen in
bielefeld kompromisse geschlossen und es
geschafft den parteiinternen streit
darüber
klein zu halten die bundesregierung will
raus aus den funklöchern und ihre
strategie beim ausbau des mobilfunks
festzurren
seit dem nachmittag beraten die minister
auf schloss meseberg in brandenburg
bereits vorab hatte das kabinett gut
eine milliarde euro für neue
mobilfunkmasten in aussicht gestellt ein
ziel der neuen strategie der internet-
standard 4g soll in ganz deutschland
verfügbar sein
nach hongkong dort eskaliert die gewalt
aktivisten haben sich in einer
universität verschanzt bogenschützen
schießen auf die polizei die droht im
gegenzug sei für munition einzusetzen
stephanie schöneborn berichtet die
polizei rückt immer näher
ihr ziel die polytechnische universität
hongkong dort haben sich protestler
verbarrikadiert viele radikale
aktivisten sind zu allem bereit mit
molotow-cocktails versuchen sie die
polizei aufzuhalten
die hat mittlerweile gedroht auch von
tödlichen waffen gebrauch zu machen
denn die protestler nicht aufhören sie
zu attackieren
jeder hier hat angst ich habe auch angst
aber wir müssen hongkong schützen
wir sind nicht stark genug um gegen die
polizei stand zu halten
ich habe angst dass die polizei hier
reinkommt die polytechnische universität
ist der letzte rückzugsort der
protestler wenn sie diesen ort
freiwillig verlassen so ihre überzeugung
waren die letzten monate des protests
umsonst mit pfeil und bogen schießen sie
und haben bereits einen polizisten
verletzt sie werfen mit molotow
cocktails und bewaffnen sich mit degen
und baseball schlägern
viele haben einen abschiedsbrief
geschrieben sind bereit zum äußersten zu
gehen
revolution hat es viele gegeben aber nur
eine samtene so nennt man den umsturz in
der damaligen tschechoslowakei
vor 30 jahren fing alles an gesicht der
neuen zeit wurde ein dichter václav
havels dessen demokratisches erbe sei
heute bedroht sagen viele
und zwar vom amtierenden tschechischen
regierungschef andré habisch einem
umstrittenen multimilliardär
so wird in diesen tagen in prag gefeiert
und protestiert britta hilpert
dies ist der ort wo vor 30 jahren in
prag die samtene revolution begann hier
eine kerze aufzustellen ist für viele
freude und mahnung zugleich so zusammen
wir müssen uns darum kümmern dass
freiheit demokratie und meinungsfreiheit
erhalten
ich will die erinnerung an den tag ehren
und sicherstellen dass sich die
geschichte nicht wiederholt
eine friedliche studenten demo ließ die
kommunistische staatsmacht am 17
november 89 hier niederknüppeln auf
massenkundgebung forderten daraufhin
bürgerrechtler wie václav havel den
rücktritt der kommunistischen führung
und freie wahl
ein generalstreik und prags größte demo
aller zeiten brachte den umsturz und
machte havel zum staatspräsidenten
gestern gingen wieder hunderttausende
auf die straße gegen die regierung der
oligarch und ministerpräsident angie
barbie die presse gefährde die
demokratie
meinen sie damit verstehen warum das
heißt die demokratie gefährden können
sie ein beispiel ich nicht wir haben auf
dem wenzelsplatz heute abend sind viele
anderer meinung dann der samtenen
revolution aber können sie es zeigen
[Musik]
heute ist volkstrauertag im ganzen land
wird an die opfer von krieg
gewaltherrschaft und terror erinnert
auch im bundestag bundespräsident
steinmeier nahmen außerdem an einer
kranzniederlegung in der gedenkstätte
neue wache in berlin teil
auf dem jüdischen friedhof in weißensee
gedachte verteidigungsministerin
kramp-karrenbauer der im ersten
weltkrieg getöteten jüdischen soldaten
österreich schweiz italien den menschen
in den alpen macht derzeit ein schwerer
wintereinbruch zu schaffen
vor allem in südtirol herrscht
schneechaos eine lawine traf ein dorf
verschüttet wurde aber niemand
häuser wurden beschädigt menschen
mussten in sicherheit gebracht werden
in einigen orten fiel der strom aus die
brenner autobahn war zwischenzeitlich
gesperrt
es besteht die gefahr dass sich weitere
lawinen lösen
zum sport hat sich die fußball
nationalmannschaft vorzeitig für die
europameisterschaft qualifiziert und
kann so das letzte spiel ganz entspannt
angehen aber relativ denn natürlich
wollen sie gruppensieger werden
das ist ganz klar 4 0 gegen weißrussland
also alles klar für die em 2020 am
dienstag das letzte spiel des jahres
gegen nordirland heute reisetag mit dem
kurzen trip vom niederrhein an den main
am abend ist das team in frankfurt
angekommen mit dabei toni kroos doppel
torschütze und mann des spiels
der große pechvogel allerdings fehlte
loki schmidt war bereits am mittag
verletzungsbedingt abgereist nach diesem
zusammenprall musste der angreifer in
einer klinik behandelt werden heute die
bittere diagnose
wer hat eine mittel gesichtsfraktur hier
in dem bereich am jochbein etwas
darunter
das dauert halt noch ein bisschen zeit
das müssen die ärzte erst einmal auch in
freiburg genau einschätzen wie lange sie
ihm eine pause geben
das war eine partie die zauberhafte tore
zu bieten hatte doch es gab auch viel
leerlauf gegen einen limitierten gegner
in dieser form zählen sie nicht zu den
titel-favoriten jetzt geht es im letzten
spiel darum den gruppensieg zu sichern
jetzt das logische ziel das man
natürlich auch die gruppe gewinnen klar
ich meine wenn man jetzt schon zwei
punkte vor den niederlanden sind dann
würde man das auch durchziehen löw
kündigte personelle veränderungen am
dienstag wird manuel neuer pausieren und
konkurrent ter stegen im tor stehen die
deutsche nachwuchsauswahl altersklasse
u21 hat in ihrer em qualifikation die
erste niederlage kassiert belgien
gewinnt in freiburg 3 zu 2 und übernimmt
damit erstmal die tabellenführung
alexander zverev muss seinen titel als
tennis weltmeister abgeben nach der
niederlage in london
sein gegner dominic thiem erweist sich
im halbfinale der atp finals in london
als der stärkere und gewinnt in zwei
sätzen mit 7 zu 5 und 6 zu 3
der österreicher beginnt in diesen
minuten sein endspiel gegen den griechen
stefanos city pass auf jeden fall ein
neuer name in der siegerliste klick
tipps zum schluss noch das wetter morgen
fällt im westen regen oberhalb von 300
bis 500 metern schnee
im osten gibt es regenschauer sonst ist
es trocken aber auftrieb
die temperatur erreicht zwei bis acht
grad im nordosten 8 bis 13 grad und die
kommenden tage bringen bei ähnlichen
temperaturen meist ruhiges herbstwetter
so viel für heute schön dass sie dabei
waren